you know i was thinking about this whole
ronnie ralph thing it stayed with me for
a couple of days like i really wanted
ralph to
answer the questions about his sexuality
and it was interesting radio that ronnie
wouldn't admit who he voted for
but right you broke my heart fredo you
broke my heart
sorry i apologize to you man that's just
all i could say
well i'm sitting here in the house with
the girl i live with and i wouldn't tell
her who i voted for
[ __ ] uh ask her ask her
why won't you tell her i won't tell her
i'm not dying
but that's the most bizarre thing yeah
why because i won't share with you
you're soon to be wife
who you're voting for you don't nope
did she tell you who she's voting for
yep
why won't you tell her what's your
reasoning
but when you say i don't want to there's
a reason why you don't want to
because i'm not telling anyone but
what's your thought behind it i stood my
ground
i'm not it's nobody's business and
that's it ronnie stop the dialogue for a
second
no no no i'm gonna ask you i'm asking
you a question and i'm
answering you you chose not to tell
stephanie who you're voting for
that's correct why i just didn't want to
tell her
don't you tell her everything i went in
another room
and did what i had to do sealed it up
and uh put it in the mail wow
they don't know i understand that but
when you make the decision i don't want
to share this information with stephanie
i didn't know she would have asked me or
she wouldn't ask me when she asked me
i said i'm not telling anyone who i'm
voting for plain and simple
i kind of i'm sorry i don't mean to
laugh it's the craziest [ __ ] thing
it's fine
what's crazy about you is i'm saying to
you okay you made a decision
maybe i said to you ron why did you make
that decision you don't even have an
answer
why not sharing it with anyone yeah i
understand that part
no one knows who i voted for and that's
the way it's going to stay
wow i'm sorry
it's fine you can laugh what you want i
don't care it's fine
what the [ __ ] is going on he's losing
his mind in quarantine
i think so i mean she told you who she
was voting for
will you stop it are you out of your
mind and nothing happened right you
didn't leave her
no what the [ __ ] is going on when do you
get these feelings that
that's it i'm not telling anyone i'm a
very stubborn person
i'm taking a stand i'm standing in a box
so i look taller
you